mi sembra l'outfit giusto per iniziare
un horror cinque anni di registrazioni
ancora non sono stanco di questa merda
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono felice oggi siamo su se mi metti il
titolo del gioco invece i crediti almeno
so che cosa stiamo giocando perché non
ho idea
l'uomo che salta a caso no mad che al
contrario si legge damon
mi sono già cagato addosso semina
inattivo da cambiar sedia presenti ok
cielo già arrivato a testa di culo è che
io c'ho il quoziente intellettivo
c'è un quoziente intellettivo è ok mi
saillard leader sì sì sì va bene ancora
una versione poco ufficiale che se fa
cagare si è giustificato e della serie
mamma ho preso 4 vale hanno preso anche
i miei compagni di classe certo che
bello
guarda il cazzo che me ne frega degli
haters o che la smetto azzurro il tasto
destro bellissimo permesso sono fa vj e
ho trovato una porta c'è solo questo
quindi entro qua non ci faccio il giro
perché io mica sono trasgressiva pro la
porta intravedo [ __ ] guarda non l'ho
passata è la pro mamma mia che persona
utile che sono intravedo sempre di più
[ __ ] con una mela in mano cos'è uno
shinigami zia senti zia comunque il tuo
outfit fa pan dan con lo sfondo
se comunque tromba bile ma cosa devo
fare
pubblica buona questa cadrega bobo are
bonissima
[Musica]
non mi aspettavo mai che sparasse sul
serio non puoi spararti se la pistola ti
entra nella faccia prima però che cazzo
cazzo che me ne frega degli haters però
al buio è un corridoio questo bello è
quando attraverso il corridoio di scuola
il lunedì mattina uguale ma il senso
cioè dove dovrei andare se c'è qualche
un televisore più figo perché il grande
fratello me lo ritrovo anche qua
oddio ma cos'è ci guarda la casa va a
fuoco facciamoci una bella foto di
gruppo che la mettiamo come copertina di
facebook siamo avanti ragazzi sticazzi
delle grande freddo è bello sto quadro
non credo che questo sia il modo giusto
per suonare un flauto però è permesso
per me sono fa vj e voglio entrare tutti
sono tutto gioioso oggi qual è il
termine esatto per definire una persona
che non vede da lontano e numerico miope
anzi come non vedo un cazzo da lontano
però ci sento molto bene questo sono non
mi piace per niente
cos'è è un uomo è un uomo bello che non
l'avevo visto neanche l'uomo pensate
quanto sono orbo orbo il termine perché
non ci vede da lontano
vabbè dopo questa lezione di dio cool
ecologia
siete proprio ferrati sull'argomento
perché io non vedo gli uomini alla
distanza perché che belle chiappe te che
hai zio quale le vedo bene cioè farvi
capire io zummo con lo sguardo e vedo
meno va verso gioco non lo capisco se
bussi nudo a una porta e difficile che
ti apre però io sono vestito almeno io
posso entrare
io io entro io io entro è uguale alla
speranza della mia vita era aprire una
porta e trovare degli uomini neri nudi
quell'ombra lidi che cos'è
spero che sia l'ombra del telefono del
telefono io passerò in mezzo agli uomini
nudi che vi devo dire
avevo dubbi
hai avuto una giornata difficile zio
avrete avuto tutti una giornata
difficile a quanto vedo però sono una
persona socievole giochiamo a risiko
[Applauso]
va bene anche il gioco dell'oca ex fate
voi vi facciano pagare tutti e due
guarda sono va bene ho visto il film
recentemente aveva sta roba qua venga un
cazzo a nessuno del finco visto toni c'è
il bene vi sono cagato addosso ma non ho
capito cosa è successo
ok a si è sfondato una porta a casa
non lo guardo il grande fratello inutile
che mi hanno propinato ogni tre non mi
fa cagare mi fa cagare
vi immaginate in un horror c'è barbara
d'urso nel televisore a porta a caso è
permesso tu lo guardi il grande fratello
protesta roba santori dio quello
tronista ragazzi uomini e donne è
sparito perché andata a rimorchiare non
si perde tempo qua questo l'ho vinto io
ogni tanto vedo gente che spuntava fuori
fuoco
c'è un corridoio solo il passaggio è
stretto tu sei nudo quindi rivolge il
tuo birillo verso il muro io passo dalla
parte opposta e si fa cadere una
saponetta
ecco una piazza che mi mette camminare
perché poi non corre il personaggio
cammino e basta
successo sono in castigo bastardi almeno
suo corridoio si vede almeno quello
questa è l'esatta rappresentazione della
posizione che ho io quando sono al
computer e non registro sono di juice
che sono così stato anche anche la massa
muscolare la stessa ragazzi non ho
capito noi stiamo andando cioè non è che
mi compaiono lo sa non ho fatto niente
iva ma che qua si dà la colpa a me
facile no per tutto si dà colpa mac un
cazzo sono stato io non ripago niente
andate a cagare grande fratello anche
qua in questo punto non vi posso fermare
a guardare i quadri anche se vorrei
tanto un altro confessionale aridaje
nomino nomino quelli quella nel quadro
di prima
ma chi è mica duce york e vacca
che cazzo è successo io io non vendo
visto giorno sento sento e basta mi sono
cagato addosso sono sentito grazie per
il manuale che non ho visto ecco questa
è la mia foto ricordo sulla tua fare
snowboard altro giorno sua finito così o
non c'è un confessionale già mi sto sono
già contento vista cosa è un po buio è
affetto
ma che ho necessariamente bisogno di
guardare un video che mi riporti un
attimo la normalità un qualcosa che
abbia senso perché dopo questa roba non
ci senso niente papi papi papi maxi uovo
di t rex i ragazzi io concludo che
l'episodio è stato un bellissimo su un
sacco soprattutto quando vai nei
corridoi e trovi di uomini nudi per
questi giochi che ho iniziato a fare
video su youtube pensate che grande
aspettativa di vita conca ragazzi
sperano che vi sia piaciuto come si
capisce il momento mi piace anche ai
giornalisti chiedendo ci vediamo al
prossimo video è tanto garda
peggio di così non è che da ragazzi
[Musica]